bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport il est 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct c'est parti pour 26 minutes de
reportage 10 match et d'interview de
sport pour la 5e année consécutive et
surtout la 5e depuis le début de
l'histoire de la course du soleil le
parénis partait ce weekend des yvelin et
demande la jolie en marche de la
première étape de cette cette édition
2014 tous les passionnés de vélo s'étent
donné rendez-vous loikmanan et Sylvain
RAC viennent de lancer footb une
plateforme dédié au football amateur
yvelinois commentaire de match et
interview des acteurs comme les
professionnels le golf de fucheru
accueillit cette semaine ce mercredi la
première étape de la foot Golf Cup 2014
l'occasion de découvrir ce sport a
priori fait pour les anciens
footballeurs et surtout en quête de
reconnaissance évidemment en fin
d'émission comme d'habitude tous les
résultats du weekend mais tout d'abord
nous partons dire direction le Maroc et
le rallyid des gazelle
2014 le 15 mars prochain sera donné le
départ de la 24e édition du rally des
Gazelles ce rallya être 100 % féminin
pendant lequel 160 équipages
traverseront le Maroc notamment dont
deux ivelinoises qui sont à mes côté
Christelle Lebert et Sophie chevalier
bonsoir à toutes les deux et merci
d'être présent sur le 78 sport bonsoir
tout d'abord première question on on en
parlait quand on on préparait l'émission
vous allez participer à votre tout
premier rally red dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes à quelques jours du
départ Christelle ultra motivé et on a
hâte d'en découdre et d'y aller et de
transformer toute la la formation qu'on
a eu puisqu'on revient du Maroc donc on
a commencé à à goûter aux dunettes et
puis ben maintenant on a qu'une hâte d'y
aller et puis et puis de voir dans la
vraie vie du rally comment ça va se
passer de votre côté Sophie j'imagine
que c'est le même sentiment d'impatience
qui domine je compte je compte les
heures les minutes même on est vraiment
vraiment très impatiente et comme disait
crestel on a on a participé à un stage
on sait ce qui nous attend et on est on
est archi prête vous êtes donc vous
faites partie un de ces 160 équipage de
ce rally de ce rally des Gazelles 2014
mais auparavant vous avez dû passer
quelques étapes de sélection au sein de
votre entreprise he vous travailler pour
la célèbre marque losange au
Technocentre c'est déjà une première
course en elle-même c'est cette
sélection non j'ai envie de dire oui
tout à fait puisque en fait on a la
chance notre entreprise à la nous donne
l'opportunité en fait de participer à ce
rally et pour cela donc il y avait
différentes
étapes à effectuer donc la première
c'était une sélection sur dossier qui a
commencé en septembre 2013 avec une
lettre de motivation et puis un CV
adapté à l'enjeu et ensuite nous n
sommes passé à la deuxième étape qui est
le fameux weekend de sélection à la base
de loisirs de 550 an liveline donc là on
a passé c'est diverses épreuves du
vendredi soir au dimanche midi avec une
course d'orientation nocturne du Bike
and Run des entretiens psychologique du
Cano et kayak démtages de roues en moins
de 3 minutes sur notre crossover et pas
pour les amateurs tout ça quand même non
il fallait il fallait se préparer mais
Sophie Sophie pourra vous en parler ça
fait un projet qu'on qu'on mûit depuis 2
ans donc donc voilà la transformation
c'est faite cette année toutes ces
épreuves Sophie c'était des des
disciplines que vous connaissiez
auparavant la course d'orientation parce
que queose d'important r cours
d'orientation oui on on avait déjà
participé à des courses avec une
association locale et même l'année
dernière on avait fait des courses
d'orientation y compris nocturnes donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui nous
avait vraiment plu donc là on était
aussi très prête pour cette épreuve par
contre on a fait lespreuv du parcours du
combattant organisé par les pompiers des
evvilines et là non on était pas très
prête non c'est notre première depuis
justement ce weekend vous avez un peu
axé votre préparation peut-être au
niveau physique pour être un peu plus
apte et prête bah on a surtout continué
notre préparation hein puisqueen fait
bon on est quand même assez sportive et
on on continue à courir pour acquérir
l'endurance qu' dont on aura besoin
durant le rally donc on a la chance de
travailler dans une entreprise qui est
très bien située à côté de la minière
donc on peut faire on peut aller courir
le midi de temps en temps quand le
travail nous le permet donc on va courir
une à deux fois par semaine pour
justement garder cette cette endurance
et puis on a également participé à à des
à des courses de quartier sur le circuit
Beltoise toujours en équipe tout ce
qu'on a fait depuis 2 ans le fait en
équipe justement comme ça ça nous permet
de nous connaître de savoir qui fait
quoi c'est devenu tout à fait
naturellement pour pour cette formation
rally justement on a on a trouvé nos
places ainsi tout à fait naturellement
donc dans quelques jours je le rappelle
vous partez pour le Maroc et ce ce rally
100 % féminin qui est le rally des
Gazelles pourquoi vous vous êtes lancé
dans ce projet Sophie c'est un défi on
aait besoin d'un de quelque chose pour
nous nous motiver aller de l'avant
savoir de quoi on était capable et
justement notre entreprise nous permet
de de de réaliser ce rêve-là euh donc
comme on s'est trouvé toutes les deux on
travaillait
ensemble donc c'est un rêve qu'on
partage et donc il fallait qu'on qu'on
qu'on réussisse les sélections pour
pouvoir
partir veut dire souvent mécanique parce
que on peut avoir des des petits soucis
dans le désert quand même il y a des des
notions de mécanique chez vous ou pas du
tout à la Basil faut savoir c'est que
nous venons toutes les deux d'un milieu
qui n'a rien à voir nous sommes dans le
contrôle de gestion donc comme quoi
l'entreprise compte nous fait quand même
confiance parce que c'est pas du tout
notre tasse de thé toutefois évidemment
on a quelques notions on a des amis
évidemment de des différentes directions
de notre entreprise qui nous ont aidé
voilà on ouvre un capot on regarde un
petit peu ce qu'il y a au niveau des
niveaux et cetera mais ce rally
contrairement à un rally classique style
Paris- Dakar le soir en fait on a la
chance on ramène nos nos véhicules à un
stand mécanique et c'est eux qui
s'occupent de tout des contrôles et
cetera nous on doit juste vérifier les
niveaux que les pneumatiques sont OK
puis savoir changer une roue pour
pouvoir se débrouiller seul si nous
devait nous arriver quelque chose
Christelle vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous êtes parti il y a quelques
jours au Maroc pour découvrir un petit
peu ce qui était le le pilotage dans le
désert comment ça s'est passé Sophie
alors cette formation a été
extraordinaire d'abord on est parti donc
ça s'adressait quand même à des à des
femmes donc comme nous issus de de
milieux différents et sans sans grande
connaissance mécanique et pilotage et
donc ça a été très crchendo en fait on a
commencé par passer des petits bans de
sable et puis à la fin du stage on a a
gravi des dunes en sablé donc on a fait
des passages de cailloux on a on a
vraiment testé tous les types de
terrains possibles et donc ça c'était
c'était très sympa on a on a eu aussi
l'opportunité de tester les plaques de
désensablage en cas de tankage donc les
pellles pousser les voitures donc et
vous avez défini à ce moment-là
j'imagine peut-être vos rôles pilote
copilote qui va qui va être au volant
pendant le rally oui tout à fait on
avait déjà une petite idée de quel rôle
on souhaitait tenir et cette idée s'est
confirmée lors de la de la formation à
savoir Sophie sera le pilote de notre
équipe moi je serai la navigatrice on
s'est tout naturellement trouvver bien
confortable dans ces deux rôles Sophie
n'appréhende rien du tout enfin elle pas
pas d'appréhension au niveau de de la du
du pilotage au niveau de la voiture elle
est super à l'aise et puis elle passe
partout avec avec le crossover et moi je
suis plus à l'aise au niveau de la
navigation et puis j'aime bien bouger
donc sortir de la voiture pour aller
voir si ça passe et dire à ma co pierre
vas-y vas-y par là par là tout doucement
ça me permet aussi de me dégourdir leses
jambes et ça me va tout à fait vous
parler de la navigation c'est un point
important et même très spécifique he de
ce rally des Gazelles puisque là on
revient un petit peu à l'ancienne
méthode hein il y a pas de GPS ça va
être la boussole et une carte c'est un
peu ça tout à fait c'est la spécificité
de ce rally ce n'est pas du tout la
vitesse qui est mis en avant mais ce
sont les talents de pilotage et de
navigation puisque l'objectif c'est
d'atteindre de trouver un certain nombre
de balises dans une journée et avec ce
nombre de balises il faut faire le moins
de kilomètres possible donc l'équipage
gagnant de l'étape sera l'équipage qui a
fait le moins de kilomètres pour pour
obtenir ces six ou 7 Balis de la journée
ouais une précision importante c'est que
la vitesse en fin de compte n'est pas
importante dans ce rally c'est vraent
VO c'est le nombre de kilomètres
parcourus et pour excusez-moi pour
parvenir à ces balises on n pas de GPS
évidemment c'est de la navigation comme
vous le disiez à l'ancienne avec une
carte des années
50 une boussole un compas à viser une
règle et un critérium et là on fait
inchallah là vous avez tout ce qu'il
faut en tout cas départ pour le Maroc le
15 mars prochain samedi après les
vérifications techniques qui vont avoir
lieu ce vendredi on vous suivra on sera
près de vous aut trocad
zu pu Nonette belleence dans quelques
semaines avec plaisir merci à toutes les
deux à très bientôt merci
beaucoup pour la 5e année je le disais
dans les titres la course du soleil
partait ce weekend des ivelines et de
Man la jolie et en marge de cette
première étape de l'édition 2014 du
Parisis les passionnés de vélo c'était
donné rendez-vous imag d'élo
diine la course du Soleil est le premier
grand rendez-vous de la saison cycliste
alors quand elle part des Yvelines les
spectateurs ne loupent pas l'occasion de
découvrir le
pleuton regardez parinus les coureurs
voir un petit peu l'envers du décor
c'est impressionnant quand même surtout
avec les voitures et tout donc c'est
impressionnant le passage d'une grande
course permet souvent de découvrir le
vélo sous toutes ses formes mais le
cyclisme c'est surtout un sport chargé
de braquet historique avec un tour de
France qui a fêté ses 100 ans 2013 les
épopées des copies antil et autres
tevennis ont marqué les passionnés ou
plutôt les cadres sur lesquels ils
réalisaient leurs exploits le système du
vélo a pas trop changé par rapport à
aujourd'hui hein des cadres en
carbone des roues ultra légères les BO
enfin on roule plus avec des boyaux on
roule avec des pneus qui est plus
facilité plus facile pour la réparation
si les ivelines semblent devenir la
terre promise du cyclisme avec le
passage régulier du Tour de France ce 5è
départ du pariniis c'est la naissance du
vélodrome de 50 ans en Yveline le monde
de la a encore quelques
kilomètres à parcourir le cyclisme est
un sport qui manque de reconnaissance
qui n'est mis en devant de la scène que
euh chaque année grâce au au au
merveilleux panorama qui est le Tour de
France on voit que Parini ça amène
beaucoup de monde c'est c'est un
événement vraiment majeur nous
effectivement notre objectif c'est de
faire venir les gens ouis à la pratique
du cyclisme que ce soit du cyclisme
promenade du cyclisme compétition tout
est ouvert ah oui et pour la petite
histoire l'espoir Français nasserbani
s'est imposé au sprint après 162 km et a
pris par la même occasion le premier
maillot jaune de
leader vous venez de lancer fotbar une
plateforme gratuite dédié au football
amateur yvelinois pour l'instant avec
commentaire de match et interview des
acteurs un peu comme en ligue bien et
vous êtes tous les deux là vous avez
couvert votre second match ce weekend
l'affiche de 2e division district Marly
Lorois Bois d'Arcy l'cmanan et Sylvin r
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être sur
le C f sport tout d'abord première
question vous avez fait et créé votre
plateforme en en septembre 2013 pourquoi
avoir décidé de donner vie à ce projet
loï pour commencer et ben en fait
nous-même on est joueurs de sport
amateur de foot amateur depuis qu'on est
tout petit et le le l'action qui nous
fait vibrer c'est le moment où on marque
un but et on se rend compte que on c'est
le moment où on va envoir une
reconnaissance internationale parce
qu'enfin on a travaillé des heures et on
va on marque ce but et en fait on se
rend compte que finalement bah ça va
concerner que nos coéquipiers du coup
l'idée ce serait de dire que aujourd'hui
le football amateur est visible partout
dans le monde au même titre que le foot
professionnel et notre objectif c'est ça
avec footbar.fr Sylvain c'était une
frustration trop importante chez vous ce
ce but non non rester dans le dans le
marbre grâce une vidéo non alors moi
faut savoir que j'étais défenseur plutôt
donc des but j'en ai pas marqué
énormément dans ma carrière mais par
contre effectivement quand j'ai commencé
le foot bah je rêvais un jour de finir
comme Zidane peu importe et bah oui au
bout d'un moment on se rend compte que
en fait on n pas forcément le talent
pour ça c'est pas pour autant qu'on
prend pas de plaisir à jouer au foot et
qu'on a pas envie d'échanger de refaire
le match avec nos amis comme si on était
pro finalement c'est aussi donneré une
belle vitrine au football amateur dont
on parle peu finalement peut-être aussi
non oui c'est ça c'estàdire que il y a
il y a les valeurs du sport amateur
elles sont elles sont souvent relaté
quand on parle des J ou ou des sports
qui sont un peu moins médiatisés que le
football le football on voit énormément
le sport professionnel qui qui draî
beaucoup de de de médias et et
aujourd'hui en fait les valeurs du foot
amateur sont sont parfaitement visible
sur internet donc on aimerait les
diffuser comment ça fonctionne cette
plateforme vous couvrez je le disais les
matchs en direct en condition de direct
avec vos caméras vos vos micros et
derrière comment ça marche si je suis
footballeur comment je fais pour voir
mon match
alors la première chose c'est un site
internet qu'on a monté parce que notre
formation nous on est ingénieur en
informatique Télécom et donc on a monté
une plateforme où les joueurs après les
matchs vont se connecter et remplissent
leurs statistiques ils disent qui a
marqué quel a été les compos les passes
décisives et cetera nous notre
plateforme derrière elle récupère toutes
ces informations et elle permet bah de
mettre en lumière les joueurs en ayant
les classements annexes des buteurs des
passeurs des classements sur les joueurs
et le dans un second temps notre travail
c'est de mettre en lumière les gens qui
ont ont brillé sur notre plateforme
parce qu'ils avaient des stats parce
qu'il faisaient des bons matchs et donc
là on fait des reportages photos sur le
terrain le dimanche et de temps en temps
on va couvrir un match en vidéo comme
s'il y avait bah l'équipe de une grosse
équipe de télé qui allait couvrir les
pros là on permet aux amateurs de se
mettre un petit instant avec le même
niveau de reconnaissance qu'un joueur
pro alors vous étiez ce weekend au match
Marl Leroi boisarcy on a posé quelques
questions évidemment aux joueurs qui
étaient concernés par votre Inter ention
on va voir un peu ce qu'il pense de de
fot bar on les écoute c'est plutôt sympa
on ahitude en amateur de d'avoir de
ligne dans le journal et encore donc
c'est plutôt sympa je pense que c'est
c'est une bonne initiative en tout cas
déjà parce qu'on fait du foot parce que
on adore ça donc on a envie de se
comparer avec ceux qu'on regarde à la
télé tous les weekends donc on a envie
de voir ce que ça donne à la télé un
match un match amateur
ça change pas ça change pas grandchose
en fait on on vient comme d'habitude on
vient pour gagner le match pu c'est tout
on va voir comment on se passe sur un
terrain coach va peut-être faire des
analyses dessus je sais pas et puis il y
a l'aspect technique qui est intéressant
c'est que vous donnez un support vidéo
pour l'entraîneur de district un petit
peu aussi hein lï oui alors là ça c'est
une grosse demande des entraîneurs et
c'est grâce à ça finalement qu'on arrive
à avoir les autorisations pour voir les
matchs c'est-à-dire que eux c'est une
occasion vraiment unique de pouvoir
revoir leur match faire des analyses
donc on leur donne vraiment accès à
toutes les données ils ont accès à
l'intégralité du match ils peuvent se
refaire des séquen sur des plans précis
et cetera pour retravailler ça avec leur
joueurs à l'entraînement pour l'instant
vous couvrez uniquement le district des
yelines où vous avez justement des
objectifs d'aller plus loin d'autres
districts en France peut-être alors
cette saison c'était uniquement le
district des Yvelines c'est vrai euh dès
la rentrée prochaine on pense être à
l'échelle nationale et et donc du coup
ça fera 102 districts partout en France
et voilà donc le but c'est de faire
parler un maximum un maximum du projet
Sylvain sur la plateforme pour l'instant
il y a combien de j'imagine d'abonnés
c'est peut-être pas le le terme précis
mais qui qui suivent vraiment
attentivement vos vidéos vidé alors les
les vidéos c'est une chose nous la
plateforme on l'a faite principalement
pour les joueurs donc les joueurs on est
à peu près à 300 aujourd'hui joueurs qui
reviennent après chaque match pour
remplir leurs statistiqu et les
consulter et puis comme vous le disiez
les vidéos bah là c'est quelque chose de
plus large qui va toucher bah la famille
des joueurs les amis ils peuvent
partager ça sur Facebook par exemple
donc on a on a une audience un petit peu
plus large vous parliez de statistique
ça veut dire que quand il les
remplissent on peut élire le joueur du
mois le gardien du mois le défenseur du
mois peut-être maintenant oui exactement
pour pour récompenser les joueurs de
nous donner ces informations notre site
génère une une fiche personnelle pour
chaque joueur qui ressemble un peu à ce
qu'on peut retrouver dans les jeux
vidéos donc on appelle ça le diagramme
PES et et derrière bah le site calcule
un score sur chaque match et du coup on
a effectivement le l'homme du match
l'homme de la semaine le joueur du mois
et on fait des reportages et des
interviews sur le fameux joueur du mois
la plateforme aussi permet peut-être à
ses joueurs amateurs de se comparer
vraiment purement au niveau statistique
avec un joueur de Ligue 1 exactement
donc on a mis récemment en place un
petit jeu Facebook qui s'appelle sequil
patron et donc on peut choisir de
comparer des joueurs à la fois deux
amateurs entre eux deux professionnels
entre eux évidemment si ça nous
intéresse et surtout un amateur et un
professionnel sur exactement la même
base de données statistique très bien
alors si les les téléspectateurs et les
footballeurs veulent vous retrouver ils
peuvent retrouver toutes ces
statistiques et évidemment j'imagine
s'inscrire
www.footbar.fr prochain match que vous
comptez couvrir c'est où dans quel coin
des iivelines pour l'instant c'est
encore en c'est on on détermine le match
qu'on va voir 15 jours avant parce qu'en
fait c'est une forme de récompense des
joueurs qui s'investissent dans la
plateforme du coup on fait grandai un
peu les enchères si vous voulez qu'on
vous filme utiliser le site et et donc
du coup on détermine ça 15 jours avant
donc là pour pour le moment sera dans un
mois donc on fait un match tous les mois
et donc voilà ils ont 15 jours pour pour
gagner le trophée des joueurs et et
avoir la récompense très bien merci
beaucoup à tous les deux donc
rendez-vous vous sur votre site pour
voir le prochain match dans lesvines
merci beaucoup à très bientôt merci
beaucoup le golf de fcherel accueillait
ce mercredi la première étape de la foot
Golf Cup 2014 l'occasion de découvrir ce
sport a priori he fait pour les anciens
footballeurs et surtout en quête de
reconnaissance images de Jonathan
villman il ne porte plus le même maillot
et pourtant il continue de frapper dans
le même ballon mais sur un parcours de
golf avec des chaussettes hautes un
gilet et un béret vous êtes au foot golf
les règles sont celles du golf sauf
qu'ici pas de club seulement des pieds
pour faire entrer le ballon dans un trou
de 55 cm de diamètre en un minimum de
coup pas si facile même quand on a
marqué près de 100 buts dans sa carrière
de footballeur attends il fini la
Goz n pas
peur ça paraît simple ça paraî simple vu
on a l'impression que que c'est très
simple et finalement les distances sont
relativement faussé par rapport un
terrain de foot c'est beauc beaucoup
plus rapproché là c'est il y a la la
distance c'est dur à jauger et après bon
il y a forcément le le le terrain petit
plat du pied voilà on n'est pas encore
fini hein c'est pour vous prouver qu'on
a encore quelques qualités de de
footballeur ouais non mais c'est vrai
que le dernier coup c'est beaucoup de
précision et c'est vrai que je pense que
on a un petit avantage par par rapport
au aux amateurs on va dire né au
Pays-Bas en 2009 la discipline compte
désormais 16 fédérations dans le monde
l'Argentine a d'ailleurs remporté la
première Coupe du monde en 2012 et la
prochaine pourrait bien être organisée
en France mais pour cela les foot
golfeerss doivent d'abord être acceptés
sur les Green
termine fin 2014 on espère avoir 2500
licenciers et à horizon de 3 ans c'est
d'avoir entre 5 et 10000 licenciés qui
puissent voilà commencer à pratiquer on
sait que pour ça de toute façon ça passe
par le fait que les que certains golfs
nous acceptent pour une pratique
régulière parce que bon venir jouer
comme ça une fois temp temp c'est
marrant c'est ludique mais c'est vrai
que je pense qu'il y en a qui peuvent
prendre et commencer à avoir envie de
jouer régulièrement comme au golf ou
comme au foot trois golf viennent de
signer un partenariat avec l'Association
Française de foot golf pour accueillir
ce nouveau sport les Pays-Bas venus en
masse à fer ont marqué leur territoire
en remportant l'épreuve par équipe de
cette première étape de la foot Golf Cup
2014 et si vous aussi vous voulez
découvrir le foot golf il vous reste
encore 14 étapes à travers la France
pour pouvoir jouer au côté de
sylvinville Thord ou encore Sydney govu
jusqu'au jour de la finale en octobre
prochain à Paris
allez on passe au résultats du
weekend en tennis de table cette semaine
et encour recevait au Palais des Sports
Saint-Denis pour la le compte de la 13e
journée de probé les joueus de franc
solelniier se sont baladés il faut le
dire et s'impose 4 matchs à Z0 avec un
seul set cédé par penelopsol elle
continue leur série impressionnante de
neuf victoires consécutives en notant de
journées de championnat et au classement
vous allez le voir évidemment et encour
est leader avec 27 points à égalité avec
Mayenne mais avec deux matchs en moins
vous le voyez autant dire que les
cinquantinoises ont leur destin bien en
main pour la montée en football 20e
journée de Division d'Honneur Versailles
s'est lourdement incliné à domicile face
au MO 3 buts à 1 les versaillers
redescendent à la 7e place de leur poule
en promotion d'honneur 16e journée dans
la poule B trappe s'est incliné 1 à0
face à Saint-Leu 2ème défaite
consécutive pour les traapistes qui
rétrogradent du coup à la 8e place dans
la poule séiguill en cours a perdu le
derby vlinois sur la pelouse du PEC 1 à0
et au classement avec cette 9e défaite
de la saison le SG désormais à la 11e
place avec 25 points à égalité de points
avec C Cloup et surtout en position de
de relégable lesiguill en courtois vont
devoir réagir très rapidement en VTT la
3è et dernière manche du challenge des
Yvelines des écoles de VTT 2014 se
déroulait ce weekend à la base de loisir
de 50 ans en Eveline près de 150 jeunes
VTTistes étaient regroupés âgés de 8 à
14 ans sur le parcours trapiste et le
niveau était élevé dans le pleuton où se
trouvaient des membres de l'équipe
île-de-fance ou encore des participants
au Trophée de France des jeunes
vtétistes malgré le beau temps de ces
derniers jours le circuit de cross
country imaginé par les organisateurs
inimontin était loin d'être une partie
de plaisir sur la selle on écoute
quelques jeun c'était dur il y avait
plein de bosses
c'était physique je je me suis suis
conservé après bah j'ai pu doubler les
autres c'est pour ça que j'ai gagné
assez grave enfin il y a des moments où
c'était assez grave et surtout dur enfin
un petit peu dur donc voilà bah ouais il
était Graas et puis il y avait des
obstacles enfin voilà il y avait
quelques petits boss des fois enfin
voilà il y avait du football féminin ce
weekend 17e journée de promotion
d'honneur et en cour recevz Vreal les
Amazones se sont imposés sur le plus
petit des scores 1 à0 grâce à cette 4e
victoire de la saison les joueur de
danilgle sont désormais 7e de leurpol
handbal 15e journée de Nationale de
féminine Montini 4e recevait le 3e Val
d'Orge et les inimontaines se sont
incliné d'un tout petit but 2423 et
perdent du coup une une une place au
classement elles sont désormais 5e et
pour terminer ce 78 sport comme
d'habitude l'agenda du weekend de
rendez-vous à ne pas rater tout d'abord
ce dimanche il y aura de laav à
Versailles les regates de versaill sur
le grand canal du château 1500 rameurs
devrai être présents sur le plan d'eau
réparti en 15 épreuve premier départ à
8h30 et finale à partir de 14h30 et ce
dimanche toujours stage d'initiation au
CRAV Maga gratuit et exclusivement
réservé aux femmes au gymnase des
pyramides de voisin le bretonux début à
10h c'est la fin de ce 78 sport merci
encore une fois de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain excellente
soirée sur
TVfil